so we have a kind of touchy-feely fuzzy
testing system highly experimental never
really been successfully done at a
statewide level going to be imposed with
taxpayers dollars on entire American
public school system and that's going to
be the big achievement together with a
kind of proto national curriculum I'm
bill Evers I am a research fellow at the
Hoover Institution at Stanford
University and I'm formerly the US
assistant secretary of education for
policy the Obama people in their
appointments put in the reformers by and
large the first thing that we saw as
their policy unfolded is all things
having to do with competition parental
choice some little incipient things that
had been allowed during the Bush
administration disappeared so Congress
had passed the law allowing opportunity
scholarships in Washington DC and this
was proven by the most rigorous kind of
academic research to give these kids
odds that they were you know doing a
year better and all is then their
socio-economically matched counterparts
second thing having to do with
competition and choice was transferring
out of schools a kind of public school
choice and under the Bush administration
they had to give the schools had to give
the parents notice if they were failing
school 15 days before the school year
started so they could try and transfer
their kid out the Obama administration
tains that to the first day of school so
effectively making it I think impossible
the third thing having to do with choice
is in the proposed revision of the
federal aid to education law of the
Elementary and Secondary Education Act
the Obama administration has gotten rid
of after-school tutoring where people
could if they were in a failing school
the parents could get a voucher and
essentially
payment saying and they could go to a
private vendor or sometimes the school
district itself but they could go and
get extra help for their kid they're
getting rid of this in their proposed
revision of the federal aid one of the
things that you hear often from liberals
is we're whale and underfunded in
education if you just pour money in the
existing system would work well so how
much money that this is often something
that no one will answer interestingly
enough Vice President Biden answered it
in a speech the Delaware teachers union
where he said the amount of money that
we're giving you both in our expanded
regular appropriations and in the
stimulus money will be enough to fix
education so I asked you whoever listens
to this we'll see now how have they
spent this money to sub specially this
new stimulus money most of it say a
hundred 23 they've put in just poured it
right into the existing system then they
have a bit set aside for competitive
grants this is the famous race to the
top that is sometimes in the headlines
because it's more interesting so states
have to fill out forms and they get
evaluated on whether their proposal for
reform makes sense now here's one of
these cases where they've given the
union's chokepoint power blocking power
veto power in order to get this money
you have to have complete support from
the labor unions and from the local
districts so these two states that are
getting the money in the first round
delaware in tennessee were able to do
this now these are states that over the
years have never shown that they were
willing to take difficult decisions
Tennessee has had all kinds of data
about individual teacher performance and
never used it in hiring and firing
decisions they have no record of biting
the bullet doing with the doing the
politically challenge
so we're now having a huge experiment on
testing there's different kinds of
testing when you're trying to do
statewide testing the more conventional
kind is multiple choice fill in the
bubble kind of thing like anything else
it can be done well it can be done
poorly but it has a lot of advantages
you can cover a lot of territory it's
fairly easy to have test security you
can correct them quickly so there's a
lot of good sites to it the President
himself and his education department has
decided no we can't have that we're
going to spend a lot of money to develop
project based portfolio base authentic
performance testing so kids are going to
submit portfolios that are going to be
graded somehow by judges this brings in
horrible subjectivity problems it's
gonna be a lot of essay writing there's
going to be a lot of projects of one
sort or another I have to say that it
could have been worse so I guess I give
them a seat boss